bon anniversaire à à à va chercher de
serviettes temps faut que j'aille twice
a aussi perdu millions ce qui se passe
je sais bon anniversaire
allez je te lèves ouais quand tu devrais
la bouche comme ça je vais lancer un
claque doigt dedans hockey au lait ou
[ __ ] j'ai failli tuer mon écran en bon
anniversaire
merci votre anniversaire à toi aussi non
non non c'est toi mais non c'est
joséphine
non j'avais des posters de toi quand
j'étais petit elle fait trop plaisir
mais bon anniversaire
non non non ce coup ci c'est pas
possible c'est mélanie j'aime bien le
sexe la grande récré dr toi tu as acheté
quoi ton petit-frère tranquille c'était
pour lui teddy chouit à la grande récré
généralement on n'achète pas autre chose
ce n'est joué c'est vrai ouais bon
anniversaire
elle pourrait y a que des mof là y'a que
des filles c'est quand que je
rencontrais l'acronyme erin là parce que
tu ne l'est pas donc voila voila on y
vient où vient le problème
ah bah voilà enfin un homme comment vas
tu veux montrer quoi tu fais pas entre
un poulet c'est quoi ton problème des
odeurs
attends je vais te montrer un truc aussi
du saumon je viens de perdre trois mois
d'auditions à cause de vous voiler
merci à tous le meilleur public du monde
je t'entends pas cette brise de cas
surprise à quoi les choses vous vous
taisez j'ai 10 ans oat et j attendais le
champomy olé cecos est entré plus
tardivement critique on entre et j'en ai
marre salut elles savent à celle là les
troubles anniversaire joyeux
anniversaire à tout aussi on est là pour
ça cinq ans maintenant cinq ans
d'ailleurs la une dernière ça faisait
combien de temps ça faisait quatre ans
du coup ça lui baptiste squeeze comment
ça va très tôt bah ça va super bien
qui te met la fessée pierre répond à
cette question au maire uniquement ma
mère mais elle a arrêté l arrêter l
arrêter
metella fait c'est plutôt avec une
ceinture ou avec un lacet plutôt avec
des bâtons oui parce que ma mère me
frapper avec des bâtons et tu rétorqué
comment je courais je parte je me
reconnais en 3d fois le corps de lâcher
tout inquiète je maîtrise mais arrêtez
pourquoi à chaque fois ci je te file du
champomy
tu dis que tu musclé tient qu'il remplit
ta part du marché hommes et squeeze il
est très musclé c'était tellement
sincère merci beaucoup pierre mazy
montois masseur jeu voire insolent
vraiment dégueu que personne ne rêve
d'avoir chez lui voilà ça et là ya du
ketchup
qu'est ce que tu fais avec cette
nourriture vous avez dit claude schopp
way pro de chez pro vie pour faire
passer bonjour françoise bonjour tu
t'appelles françoise et non à thouars
j'essaye donne moi la première lettre s
ça bonjour sophy
bonjour samantha bonjour sa mère si tu
veux un petit peu de champomy n'hésite
pas j'en ai plein en stock
ah non c'est bon j'ai mon jus d'orange
lesquels elle m'a gâché oui mais c'est
quoi non mais ça doit être un homonyme
je vois si bercy doit aussi phrase
banale fois que ça va ou quoi sommes
nous à fagah tôt pour un souffle
ensemble 50 bah oui alors obligé
plaisir faire merci tout aussi peu
partout quoi ma soeur elle savait chatel
jadel ou charnel shy'm adhérer et sont
tous cassés ces numéros 5
chatel mais non mais non
comment ça va avec toi bah ça va super
bien je te souhaite un bel air voilà on
est synchro n'est pas encore question où
va pas être en cours là je suis malade
comme la chanson sublime halle à deux
c'est bien la réponse est oui jackson
puis je vous dis à très vite dans une
prochaine ça bug a résumé un foulard au
cas où on confondrait avec oui
attends je sais pourquoi je suis
contente de rencontrer parce que j'ai
trouvé des cheveux encore plus nawak que
les miens ça ne va trop bien [ __ ] ça
bute et te souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire joyeux anniversaire merci
beaucoup
attends je t'ai pas vu la dernière fois
toi déjà hélas pour les quatre à temps
c'est abusé on se trouve en dehors après
c'est génial je vous souhaite un joyeux
cinq ans je t'entends pas ne tentant pas
nous entend pas quelle est cette
sorcellerie pourquoi tu à découper un
citron elle a déposé sur ton visage
ol by elle pas hélas goinfre elle est
fatiguée qu'est ce que c'est un rond ça
c'est un carré frais c'est un test de
psychologie c'est ça ok baccouche de sa
jeune adversaire petit confetti
merci pour ton pièces de psychologie en
bois - les résultats par mail et à très
vite
oh [ __ ] bonjour tu as tué ta maman
c'est ça comment que je fais tu as gagné
ce bouchon moi je sais sa bouche au fait
qu amour
moi je peux t'offrir un magnifique petit
gâteau au chocolat que j'ai fait
maintenant ça me touche arrête salue les
sharp
comment ça va bon anniversaire les chars
pas je te souhaite un bon anniversaire à
plus pour ses bottes boursiers aux
mécaniques ont fait je pensais pas
devoir la question fout là je suis pas
bon du tout dans ce coup ci les
anniversaires du coup j'ai mis ça sur
aux véhicules des gros appareils
moi je suis pas du tout prêt du coup mes
attentes j'ai du coup moins que tu fais
un petit coup là je vais prendre un
petit verre
et c'est pas ma frite la cocaïne moi
j'ai du chauffe eau mis au petit nier up
mais à nature voilà ton avis et quel âge
européen et donc g20 il y avait ce
morceau de ferraille a gagné voilà tu
peux être maîtrisé en fin de morceau de
ferraille mais chantier deuxième chance
qu'elle reste yat-il après le pédant
champomy allez tu peux le faire baptiste
bon pop et ainsi gagner ses galons
on va faire le fameux a très vite dans
une prochaine vidéo tu diras vidéo et
ensuite y aura tous les to les vidéos
des gens au fait qu'ils vont s'enchaîner
que j'en convient vidéo ça s'enchaîne
rassure donc du coup est à trouver dans
une prochaine vidéo
et voilà j'en suis fière de cette vidéo
j'espère c'est aux appuis je vous
souhaite à tous un joyeux anniversaire
mène à ceux qui n'ont pas pu être sur ma
gueule parce qu'ils étaient en cours ou
quoi je suis désolé fallait bien que je
tourne la vidéo un jour et c'est tombé
sur le vendredi après midi pendant que
vous étudiez d'histoire géographie
vous avez remarqué la rime ou pas merci
merci merci d'être si nombreux suivis
des vidéos après cinq ans [ __ ]
j'espère ça vous plaira encore longtemps
ça me touche énormément vous m'avez dit
plein de belles choses aujourd'hui sur
omegle et puis on remet ça l'année
prochaine j'espère que vous serez
nombreux
j'espère qu'on se verra aussi avant vrai
à des conférences ou des salons ou des
trucs des eaux là dessus qu'ils sont
venus sur ma gueule et qui n'ont pas
croisé mais vous étiez des milliers donc
avec de faibles chances cette poignée de
confettis et pour vous et uniquement
pour vous et où elle je fais de gros
bisous forte ou bien je te dise